a bit of a late recording start here
hello and welcome to see your English
bar 64 played on the forum won all the
games that's good ya know I thought that
in this kind of position type should
give white a slight advantage with the
bishop pair even though bloggers of
course extremely solid and is he going
to play before and maybe he is I'm not
sure about this move by the way I'm just
kicking it back if I've weakens a lot do
you really get enough activity maybe
it's got f4 I just noticed that no I
don't understand a single move why does
that work even but yeah I mean ok see
for was hanging but this how do you
cover the night I mean like 27 I go
Queen d2 and those nights look bad yeah
can still take okay and that's a piece I
don't need to go back by the way but
that looks well I have one I cannot
blunder it that's definitely an upside
of the movie
okay it's still a rock right black
resides I hoped you one also was quite
good yeah now that that was a weird way
to handle the opening either distance
must be equal ish i think the engine
agrees I like white I have to say
because I'm just such a bishop and nuts
but don't think it's anything special
yeah I tried before to make him move the
hanging pawns there I want a little bit
about potentially f4 that looks loose
now that makes sense mature just to bust
open this position there are too many
weaknesses IAM and then that I just
didn't understand i think it doesn't
work and i mean you can also just stay I
mean just keep the position as it is I
mean I wanted to open the B file and
weaken the pawns a bit but it's nothing
special yeah just tell just googles of
stuff okay yeah that just lose material
in general what I think is interesting
is that in this line I think most of the
time the beef or III based development
is better than g3 I usually just play it
play it like that I mean I don't know
much theory here just play play moves
and I think yeah why this is perfectly
fine ok guys thanks for watching